[Musica]
qualche anno fa coral lawrence disse
parafrasando lo più o meno un battito
d'ali di una farfalla in messico
potrebbe scatenare un uragano in brasile
ve la ricordate questa frase chissà
quante volte tu io noi facciamo battere
le ali e non ci preoccupiamo
dell'effetto che stiamo producendo la
parola chiave di questo incontro come
ben sapete sostenibilità la sua abilità
è una parola che ultimamente si sta
cercando di affrancare ma al contempo
rischiamo molto di banalizzarla io ho
provato a darvi una prospettiva di
natura scientifica partendo addirittura
dalla fisica quantistica state con me la
fisica quantistica approvato che esiste
un campo energetico universale che da
questo campo energetico immenso noi
riceviamo e mandiamo energia
l'origine di tutto fu il big bang
l'esplosione che creò tutto ciò che
esiste prima del big bang tutto era uno
come sostengono tutte le grandi
tradizioni religiose del mondo e dopo il
grande big bang l'uno si diviso e ha
creato la vita in tutte le sue forme
grazie alla fisica quantistica al
comportamento delle particelle ora
sappiamo che i più piccoli elementi
atomici quanti si comportano come se
fossero ancora parte di questo grande 1
inoltre approvato che tutto ciò che era
unito non perde mai la sua connessione
con il resto quindi ne deriva che
qualsiasi cambiamento anche il più
piccolo influenza il tutto questo
estratto ci sono fisici in sala no non
mi credete non vi fidate andate a
verificare questo è ciò che recentemente
la fisica quantistica avrebbe scoperto
perché mi interessa raccontarvi tutto
questo perché c'è anche questo
esperimento molto interessante si chiama
entanglement hanno preso un atomo di
materia non separato in due parti uguali
poi hanno agito su una delle due parti
identiche all'altra che era pro distante
chilometri di anni luce
è l'altra parte è mutata nella stessa
maniera in cui è mutata quella su cui si
è agito sto cercando di dirci che siamo
tutti interconnessi gli uni dagli altri
ciò che tu dici fi pensi provi agisce su
questo insieme quindi la riflessione
prima voglio fare con voi e qual è la
nota che io costantemente e metto perché
questa nota sta andando a contribuire a
cambiare l'intero universo ci devi
credere in nome di dio o ci devi credere
in nome della scienza scegli tu
ma qualunque tuo pensiero azione
emozione sentimento gesto sta
condizionando l'intero universo è una
scoperta a tutti sun troppo logico per
l'umanità incredibile perché mai come in
questo tempo l'umanità ha preso atto non
coscienza atto che può incidere sul
tutto poi valere uso dire il futuro non
è più quello di una volta io da parecchi
anni mi diletto a studiare con altri
esperti in giro per il mondo soprattutto
filosofi artisti scienziati ed
economisti quelli che sono i grandi
scenari che si stanno prospettando
all'orizzonte li chiamano mega trend ci
sono tre date che sono state adottate da
tantissimi anni un ormai le porte sono
2020 2030 2040 5 a ridosso delle quali
si presume che questi grandi trend che
queste grandi tendenze si manifesteranno
agli occhi di tutti se tu fai un'impresa
se tu sei anche un privato in cittadino
un genitore qualunque cosa tu faccia
nella vita il trend va intercettato
prima non te ne devi accorgere quando
compare perché quando compare sera un
iceberg cipicchia rai contro si erano
opportunità sarà persa per sempre e non
è solo per il mutuo no di chi ne ha
anticipato prima che una casa coincide
più o meno con il 2045 ma se voi dovesse
andare a vedere le grandi ricerche
vedrete che ricordo queste scadenze i
quattro e quattro grandi direttrici che
ridisegnano il pianeta tendenzialmente
da qui ad allora pilato card entità
proiettati cerca di vedere quanti anni
avrai per allora sono uno la demografia
il pianeta si sta completamente
ripopolando secondo flussi migratori
economici non solo i barconi in un
flusso via veramente opposto a quello
che è stato
il flusso che ha caratterizzato le
epoche a noi noti di cui noi siamo
risultato ultimo si sta andando da sud a
nord e da est a ovest non più da nord a
sud e da ovest ad est
guardate qual è la crescita la
popolazione mondiale nella storia
dell'umanità guardate la concentrazione
che c'è stata in questo tempo dovete
prefigurarsi come se tra pochissimo
tempo in questa stanza ne fossimo prima
due poi 48 volte tanto prima due poi 4
poi otto volte tanto per capire che
cambierebbero immediatamente tutte le
regole sociali di questo luogo uguale di
ammazzare ste come cani per un pezzo di
pane
erano un bicchiere d'acqua alle regole
sociali non sarebbero più in essere due
l'ambiente il dato qui è terrificante
gli ultimi 25 anni abbiamo distrutto 10
per cento della flora della fauna di
questo pianeta negli ultimi 25 anni
abbiamo distrutto 10 per cento di un
luogo ci ha ospitati per milioni di anni
l'anno scorso ad agosto il pianeta ha
consumato la sua capacità di dare
risorse stante la domanda che noi
facevamo stanzialmente entrato in
riserva ciascun paese al suo of two days
l'italia quest'anno entrati riserva al
17 di luglio di quest'anno perso trend
che ridisegnerà il pianeta la tecnologia
l'unica vera equazione esistente oggi al
mondo che interessa tutti è questa io
sono andato recentemente in vacanza con
i miei figli alle maldive a pasqua uno
sforzo importante essendo noi in vii e
vi assicuro che l'unica domanda che per
mesi ci siamo fatti quando non pianifica
le vacanze era sempre una cosa mi
chiedevo le mie figlie
c'è wifi quindi siamo sceso nelle
salette alle maldive e mezza dalle scene
come dei rabdomanti siamo nati sotto le
palme cercare mediamente questa cosa è
la prima volta nella storia dell'umanità
che tutta l'umanità può essere
interconnessa l'uno con gli altri
semplicemente schiacciando un bottone
non credete a questo sul prodotto sul
web quando un prodotto gratuito tu sei
il prodotto la tecnologia sta che vi
hanno descritto poc'anzi chi mi ha
preceduto sta rimodellando completamente
con la materia plastica e dunque il
fatto il nostro cervello i nostri figli
percorreranno processi neurologici
diversi dai nostri cercando interazione
con la
diversamente come l'umanità ha fatto
fino ad ora e questo pervaderà qualunque
attività della specie umana perché vi
dico tutto questo perché stiamo
addirittura arrivando di gridare le
macchine uomo e macchina e siamo entrati
in questo momento storico per la prima
volta nella storia dell'umanità in cui
si è innescata una cosiddetta curva
esponenziale
quando si fa però velocissimi si
potrebbe anche rischiare di andare a
sbattere qualche anno fa ebbi la fortuna
di incontrare questa donna e la nipote
del mahatma gandhi la figlia il
quartogenito della grande anima mahatma
grande anima significa che visse quello
ne lasciano fino all'età di 14 anni tara
gandhi tara mi disse che suo nonno era
solito ripetere costantemente questa
frase tara non è la velocità che fa la
differenza ma l'orientamento perché vi
dico questo perché nel frattempo noi
siamo stati una specie capaci di ridere
l'atomo ne siano state una specie capace
a dividere il pane perché non abbiamo
scritto una carta incredibili sui
diritti le libertà di qualunque essere
umano a carte diritti dell'uomo non
abbiamo saputo affermare difendere
queste libertà è questi diritti per
tutti gli esseri esistenti su questo
pianeta ci ricorda che siamo partiti
questo e traffico di organi dal dato
siamo tutti interconnessi lo dico per
chi pensa ad esempio che la cosa non lo
riguardi qui non lo riguardi che in
questo momento il 99 per cento alla
popolazione una ricchezza pari all'uno
per cento più ricco del pianeta e che
ben otto persone sul pianeta terra ma
una ricchezza pari alla metà restante
più povera fonte world economic forum
quindi dobbiamo tornare all'essenza
delle cose
martin luther king era solito dire può
essere che tu non sia responsabile per
la situazione in cui ti trovi in ma lo
sarai se non farei nulla per cambiarla
il mio auspicio è che questo volto che
spesso caratterizza anche la mia vita si
trasforma in questo volto
il mio auspicio che qualunque essere
umano su questo pianeta qualunque sia la
sua sfera di influenza
esattamente come nuovo decide di
rompersi dall'interno perché quando un
uomo si rompe dall'esterno alla vita che
in esse contenuto muore quando un uovo è
rotto dall'interno atto consapevole e
cosciente la vita che in esse contenuto
nasce nuova origine dopo i flussi
demografici la sensibilità l'ambiente e
la pervasività della tecnologia nelle
nostre vite il 4 il quarto grande i
driver che si dice l'ingegner al pianeta
completamente a cavallo tra il 2020 2045
sarà l'etica i valori e comportamenti
perché vi dico questo stiamo per fare
nuovi incontri
questo sei tu alla nascita
guardate questa sequenza di immagini che
bellezza qualche anno fa
un fotografo danese per la prima volta è
riuscito nella storia dell'umanità a
fotografare ogni istante di tutto questo
magico processo ci ha messo 12 anni con
una telecamera molto molto particolare
guardate la magia di questa sequenza
ma sopra sta affiggendo
[Musica]
figlia è mamma
e normale sembra da uomo e chi un soc i
files ombre
[Musica]
sono felice che tu abbia sorriso la mia
domanda e da quanto tempo non ci
facciamo certe domande
le macchine sono fatte per dare risposte
gli esseri umani sono fatti per farsi
domande
le macchine sono un programma l'essere
umano è un progetto quindi prefigurare
una nuova origine per me è fare una
rivoluzione o meglio una ri evoluzione
di un nuovo stato di coscienza
c'è una cosa che a mio parere può
salvare qualunque si singolo essere
umano sulla terra
noi siamo destinati a scomparire
sant'agostino diceva siamo poco più
degli animali poco meno degli angeli
quindi o scompariremo te l'hanno detto
che devi morire si è che non ti porterai
di ha nulla di tutto ciò che ha
accumulato sì si no quindi o cadremo a
terra o qualcosa
porterà verso l'alto io credo che ci
debba portare verso l'altro la vocazione
sul vocabolario la vocazione una
particolare sensibilità un trasporto in
atto nel vivere un certo tipo di vita
che porta l'individuo a fare alcune cose
piuttosto che altre per le quali sento
un trasporto interiore e in filosofia si
intende quella chiamata sentirsi
partecipi di un progetto universale o
inutile proprio e ognuno il proprio
ambito specifico
io non so quale sia la tua sfera di
influenza ma io so che tu puoi
influenzare il tutto l'economia
circolare ad esempio tornando nel mio
mondo non è più sufficiente
è una soluzione di breve ad un problema
che oggi è diventato centrale il mio
auspicio è un'economia sferica che metta
l'uomo al centro di tutto l'ora di chi
ha le sue origini e grazie alla sua
vocazione gli consenta di a sperare una
dimensione universale impattando su 7
piani dell'umanità ti lascio
ricordandoti che il mondo si dimenticava
di qualunque cosa tu avrai detto di
qualunque cosa tu avrei fatto ma non di
come l'avrei fatto sentire se puoi
fai della tua vita un dono e fai di
questo dono qualcosa di significativo
per l'insieme
grazie
[Applauso]